it's about as far removed from a
farmer's field as you can imagine but in
the sterile dish in a Maastricht lab
they're growing beef these are cells
taken from a cow and they're making
burgers yeah it tastes like meat scale
up the process and it could feed the
planet's appetite for meat but with a
fraction of the greenhouse gases of
living cattle this is a way to create
exactly the same tissue that we know but
without the cow at least not so many
cows so that will reduce the
environmental impact and it will allow
us with much less resources to grow much
more meat that's the whole point to
satisfy the craving of the hardcore
meat-eater for me beef has a huge carbon
footprint a small 100 gram burger
results in up to 105 kilograms of
greenhouse gas the same amount of lamb
produces just 27 kilograms pork and
chicken are far lower and veggie protein
sources like peas and pulses produced
just 300 grams they barely figure a
former government chief scientist has
told Sky News he stopped eating beef and
he's giving up lamb and we have a moral
imperative to do the same there's no
question we need to do it one of the
issues is not just our behavior here in
Britain it's the example we set to
others so my behavior has to reflect
what I expect from everybody the UK's
cattle and sheep produce around 21
million tonnes of greenhouse gases every
year a natural byproduct of their
digestion but the government's own
advises on climate change style weight
than calling on us to give up meat
altogether they say that while cutting
back would certainly reduce Britain's
carbon footprint they believe that
wouldn't be public support for the huge
behavior change required meat
consumption in the UK has fallen 3% over
20 years but beef is holding steady for
many it's hard to give up I think it's
probably like you haven't grown up with
it so
hamburgers you know a steak was always
like a special occasion so I think you
know it was like a you know a decent
fancy meal what's in your lunch cuz I'm
not quite there and I will admit that
time for tougher action says this
behavioural economist attacks in the UK
as I said beef consumption would need to
be 20 percent more expensive milk
consumption 10 to 15 percent more
expensive then just to include climate
damages what is clear is providing
information is not alone so we really
have to think about more progressive
policies that would help the consumer
make the right choice
the government's advisors conclude that
planting trees could offset greenhouse
gases from livestock and allow us to
meet international commitments on global
warming but other scientists argue that
just dodges the problem and that beef
however tasty should be off the menu
Thomas More Sky News